[Music]
[Music]
um
i don't know i feel like there's just a
little bit too much mutiny around here
sometimes
well so your concern is that one of us
passed you or your concern is somebody
that's
not part of the crew pastor it's all
dangerous do you understand that when
united
you we stand divided we fall is my point
if we're going to rage this foot war
we can't be spreading our light light
allegiances all over the place
there's one foot commander and you guys
been on this course
the scoreboard compromises all of our
hard work
we cannot compromise the security of
this war well for okay so
you're gonna lose we all lose okay first
of all this is a this is a fluid
situation
okay because when that happened
all i said is that it would be funny if
a b passed you
because a b was like freaking out
about like ethan's gonna be mad at me if
i pass him i'm like well that would be
funny then
[Music]
who do you guys think you are i'm the
foot
god you don't pass me
this is my foot throne
a b a god
[Music]
four thousand one hundred five star
ratings you forget yourself
you're by now i ask you all today now to
pledge allegiance to me as your one true
leader of the foot nation army
this is really how wars happened we had
this common
thing and you guys got greedy you all
wanted foot clout i
do want to have your own foot nation you
weren't just happy being under
and being under my shirt i was happy
nobody i didn't put myself on there
they're like little [ __ ]
you're causing trouble you're trying to
break chaos i'm not like you know
you are not like you know what you're
like joffrey you're like joffrey no i'm
not you've gone
insane with power you're out of control
start listen to this a b said oh i'm
doing to protect you
now all of a sudden when i'm like yo i
don't like what's happening here you're
talking about oh i'm ready to go mutiny
and make my own nation and then what do
i got to do i got to go war with you
and i got to go war with you and then
all of a sudden this nation we had
unified
strong the top in the world is now weak
with war and attrition and infighting
i think you need to eat you are
floating this is equivalent to julius
caesar finding out that he's been
betraying yes
he too brutus e2 dan
dan is the main perpetrator you know
julius
no julius you are julius you're judas
and i am jesus okay we're we're mixing
up our metaphors here a little bit now
the point is i'm the foot savior and you
all have
been about to be
ian who do you pledge allegiance to
i think ian hates me
love who do you support you of course
thank you you're all fired
love is executive producer i've always
supported it oh jack is excited zach is
promoted
i've never wanted this mutiny to happen
yeah
you're in love you're in ian you're in
the [ __ ] school
what did they call that when you they
put his prisoners in
yeah you're in the gulag
i'm just saying this feels like how
democracy yo
getting that out of here i am the senate
yeah you're going to the gulag bro get
that out of here
abc you're going your head is going on a
pike
you